those are the three i want you to check
out before we have full-fledged x-men
because they're just around the corner
because this my friends was the last
marvel property before comic con and
there are no coincidences at marvel this
is 10 days out from hall h i think hall
h is gonna be
i think we're gonna hear that theme song
and i'm very excited about it
[Music]
reject nation we are shooting this
immediately following the miss marvel
finale the finale for miss marvel was
incredible this is going to be chock
full of spoilers for the finale so if
you haven't seen the finale go watch
that first come on back to us the finale
was everything we're gonna get into how
this finale and this show shapes the
entire future of the mcu this show
more than maybe any other phase four
property i think is going to be
essential for the cohesion of phase four
we're gonna get into all of that but
before we do like subscribe hit that
bell leave a comment i want to know what
you think of these theories i want to
know what you thought of the episode i
want to know what you think of the comic
rex i gave you just let me know also
anything else you guys would like to see
discussed on this very show and if you
like this show check out my tick tock
i've got 15 second 30 second one minute
three minute more concise videos of
these ramblings that i pump out like
three to five a day so it is chock full
of this exact thing but stream of
consciousness craziness with some
graphics all right this
is mutants
this is a moment we have wanted since
the mcu the x-men
spider-man blade
were the trilogies and then beyond but
those were the foundations that allowed
marvel to exist we've wanted to combine
those things since the mcu started since
we had this the pipe dream was somehow
having spider-man in there and we
accomplished that then it was somehow
having fantastic four and we know that's
coming then this insane dream of maybe
having the x-men in there and somehow
incorporating all these characters we
love into this world and there's been so
many theories there's the idea of maybe
the snap people came back they've got
mutation maybe mutants have been around
in parallel universes and they invade
ours maybe incursion events cause
mutants to be from another planet and
mix with ours any number of things that
any number of people much like myself
have gone that's how i i do mutants we
now know
how we're getting mutants because we've
been living with a mutant for the last
six weeks kamala khan has a mutation and
dinan and that she is a mutant i think
this is up there with
retconning some of the aspects of civil
war which is ironically going to come up
in a minute to make the movie work
better the thing about comic books and
comic book adaptations is they need to
be adaptations not translations the
x-men universe is vast it is insane the
inhumans universe is also very weird and
specific the kirby-isms of all those
things are beautiful and they work this
is nothing against the inhumans but when
you've already got the avengers
established for 14 years when you've
already got characters like spider-man
and all these other things it's hard to
do both in humans and mutants so i think
what what kevin feige did was he wanted
the people that are giant and humans
fans to have that taste and we got black
bolt in multiverse of madness and that
was a moment of like i want them to get
there in humans i want that for them
because kevin feige is a nerd he gets
what people want so i think that was a
taste and i think that inhumans are just
not going to be in this world i don't
think inhumans are going to be in the
mcu at least not for like a decade
mutants being how we start to
extrapolate from the world that hates
and fears them is genius so i've been
saying this for a few months this is one
of the most gratifying things that one
of the things i hoped would happen one
of the things i dreamed and theorized
would happen when it lands it feels so
special not in a sense if i told you so
but in a sense of like i'm thinking the
same way this is going and this is
fulfilling a lot of my nerd adaptation
dreams so i've been thinking kamala is
going to go through something that
happened in the comics i believe called
kamala's law and that is when the events
of civil war occurred in the comics as
well and through the sokovia accord they
tried to pass this thing where you had
to register if you were a superhero
people took sides tony wanted to as he
always does build a protective layer
around the world and he thought
registering people having regulation
having rules was the way to get that
through cap was on the other side of
like liberty and freedom and this is not
just and i don't believe in these rules
and that is a similar and then they went
their own way with the movie they only
have the comics they differ from there
now what's interesting is that obviously
failed in both the movies and the comic
books but years later more recently
kamala's law is basically okay you you
superheroes you go do your thing we
can't control you you're way too much
kamala basically is a child she gets
very very very injured as kamala khan
and they pass a law that superhero
children cannot
work and do the super heroics without
some sort of registration this goes
through this is accomplished so all of
the champions which are our young
superhero team are basically on the run
they're illegal they're doing things
like vigilantes but fully illegal
there's entire government entities like
the dodc as in ms marvel hunting them
down in the comic books the people that
are hunted down the most that are
children are the children of the [ __ ]
atom it was right in front of us the
whole time they're geniuses they're
combining these storylines we're getting
children being hunted down because the
world that hates and fears them we're
getting regulation we're getting that
beautiful line from a kamala khan where
it says that's just another label we've
had a mutant and we probably have other
mutants because they've established that
we just haven't looked and it's going to
be amazing to see how this goes one of
the things i love is that through comron
who is a new human which is a variation
of an inhuman in the comic books he's
always looked kind of like iceman to me
and they made his his power set looked
very much like the comic books and i've
always thought like it's really
interesting how it's just a phraseology
of inhuman versus mutants in many cases
not in origin not in powers all those
things but if you're if you're a
day-to-day fan if you're if you're not
versed in this you wouldn't be able to
tell the difference necessarily between
someone who's crazy medusa hair was a
mutation versus an inhuman thing they're
they're very akin to each other you know
what i mean like certain characters are
parallel this is a great way to
streamline and we're invested because of
how incredible obama vilani is how
incredible the show was it gives us all
the family elements that are important
kamala khan's family are so important to
her story so we're gonna deal with the
world starting to hate mutants and how
that feels for her we're gonna deal with
other mutants being you know let go by
their family being like expelled because
of this label because of this thing and
then we're gonna also see all the racism
of it what better place to start a show
about prejudice than a show about a very
important muslim character this show
addressed head [ __ ] on that the
government keeps an eye on mosques it
judges people by their religion by the
way they look who they are that's
[ __ ] prejudice that's the x-men we're
going into a world from a world of
prejudice that exists in our world we
live in a world that judges people for
who they are the x-men have always been
a beautiful metaphor for so many things
lgbtq lives for racism for all of these
things that humans do to hate each other
humans suck at taking care of humans and
the x-men have always been a very
beautiful very not-so-subtle look at
what that is as much as captain america
is about politics the x-men are about
humanity and it talks about humanity
there's characters like the brotherhood
of evil mutants the friends of humanity
they're not subtle bringing this all in
through miss marvel is the best way to
make sure that you're endeared but also
that you're not missing the [ __ ]
message that we got to take care of each
other not only does this bring us
mutants not only does it set it up in a
way that feels so natural just like
laying groundwork for these characters
just like civil war felt natural because
iron man was so fleshed out and captain
america so fleshed out that when they
punched each punch landed twice with ms
marvel were so invested this felt so
natural that mutation just made so much
sense and now we're there so i think
department of damage control is going to
establish these laws i think these laws
are going to be passed potentially in
shield i think we're going to hear
rumblings of all these things so i think
while miss marvel is out in space with
captain marvel and spectrum or photon
whatever they end up calling her i think
that is going to be going on setting up
the cree scroll war which brings us into
secret invasion on this earth she-hulk
and daredevil who's coming back are
going to be dealing as the first
superhuman well she looks publicly
superhuman because she's green she can't
hide it but they're going to be dealing
with the superhuman regulations we're
going to see laws get passed we're going
to see regulation and we're going to see
it not just about superheroes we're
going to see it about mutants they've
said the word everybody's heard that the
bird is the word the mutants are here i
think throughout shield we see that i
think we see the follow-up to this first
in the marvels then in secret invasion
and then when she comes back that's what
all this is i think her bangle wanted to
find its pair so she got bonked out to
space and got swapped with captain
marvel so i think that scene might
literally be in captain marvel to the
marvels and we see the other side of
that but either way i think she just got
jettisoned out into space so we're not
going to see her ramifications of these
actions so i think it's a really
important thing to then live in the
world of she-hulk with these rules again
this is a theory i don't know if that's
what she hopes about but it'd be
interesting if it goes that way in the
meantime i just want to celebrate the
fact that a show as powerful as this as
important as this is bringing some of
the most important comic characters to
us and it's doing it very soon because
we've had six weeks of a mutant on our
screens and that's kamala khan before i
get out of here i want to give you guys
some comic recommendations about the
x-men we've wanted x-men in the mcu for
so long god loves man kills this is the
comic that basically made x2's
foundation if you love x-men 2 this is
the comic for you this deals with the
prejudice against mutants in a very
political way my next recommendation is
gifted this is joss whedon's beginning
foray into the astonishing x-men i
actually recommend you read the entire
astonishing x-men run but a specifically
gifted deals with people trying to get
rid of their powers i imagine with
kamala khan and these power things and
children having powers there is gonna be
an element of people wanting to cure you
people wanted to get rid of the othering
people wanted to get rid of their
problems gifted deals with what it means
to have powers in this world in that
context check it out and then finally e
is for extinction this is a little
deeper into the mythos this is grant
morrison and frank quietly this is the
beginning of the new x-men run when they
change the numbering around and this is
basically the government using sentinels
and things to hunt down mutants in a
very very racist way that really hones
in on a lot of the elements of hate that
i think are gonna come in to the miss
marvel version of how they bring into
mutants basically politics cheering and
hate through government entities are the
direction i think they're taking miss
marvel so what a great way to kick off
comic-con next week what a great way to
kick off the x-men in the mcu and what a
great way to finish with one of the best
finales in the mcu thank you reject
nation like subscribe leave some
comments let me know you thought of this
video let me know what other things you
want to see and most of all uh don't be
a dick because x-men is about not being
a dick be good to people much love